particular D68 which did cause some
severe illness in children and that
we're seeing is settling down we also
saw a rise in respiratory Sensational
virus or RSV and our data shows that is
also leveling off
and covid-19 remained steady and
particularly affecting older adults
reminding us of the importance still of
booster doses with the bivalent vaccine
that we know gives greater protection
against covet 19.
in our last briefing we had started to
see the dramatic increase in influenza
particularly influenza A that is
increasing and it's continues to
increase
in September and in November we
reiterated the importance of protecting
children in particular six months and
older from influenza and we've not seen
much influenza in the past two years
primarily because of the restrictions in
travel we know that influenza spreads
around the globe when and it moves with
people as we move around the globe and
we had been watching what was happening
in the southern hemisphere particularly
Australia New Zealand and as we talked
about in September and November they saw
an early increase in influenza and
particularly influenza A in their winter
season and we were concerned that we
would see the same thing here and that
indeed has come to pass we've seen a
dramatic increase in influenza A and
it's earlier than we would normally see
it this early peak in influenza
influenza has started early and it's
mainly influenza A
H3N2 that's causing illness that we're
seeing around the province now and we
know from previous experience with
influenza that H3N2 does tend to cause
more severe illness across the board but
particularly in young children and in
older people
and there are more children now who have
not been exposed to influence influenza
for the last two to three years because
of the lack of circulation of influenza
that we've seen so more of them are
getting sick now and we see that
reflected in absenteeism in our schools
where people are keeping children home
when they're sick and this past week
we've heard from pediatrician colleagues
in particular from BC Children's
Hospital and from hospitals around the
province that they're starting to see
and hear more about severe cases of
influenza and in some cases
complications from influenza we know
much more than than covet influenza can
cause more severe illness in children
especially young children and it can
lead to secondary bacterial infections
with things like streptococcus or
pneumococcus that can cause very severe
pneumonias and so that's the concern
that we have right now
normal influenza Seasons before covid we
would see this type of a move through
our population usually about six to
eight weeks we'd have Peaks and they
they would change over time and in
Canada we would have about 2500 to 3
000 people who were affected and died
from from influenza and about somewhere
between 15 to 20 000 people who were
hospitalized across the country so
that's the before times so what we're
seeing now is more typical from what a
usual influenza season before covet but
it's happening earlier
and as I said it does take about six to
eight weeks for it to move through the
population we still have time to blunt
the impact of this transmission by
getting people vaccinated I cannot
stress enough the importance of
influenza immunization right now this
year in particular as the best
protection we have against infection and
severe illness from influenza and
particularly for children who we are
seeing being effective right now
influenza vaccines are available for
free for everyone over six months of age
in British Columbia and we have enhanced
vaccines for seniors over age 65.
just to remind people those most at risk
of severe illness or these complications
from influenza are children under the
age of five and I will say that there
are nasal spray vaccines for for
children 2 to 17 years of age if they
have concerns about needles
older children and adults with chronic
conditions like lung disease or heart
disease
pregnant people at all stages in
pregnancy the vaccine protects both you
and your child and gives protection to
the baby for the first few months of
life where there's no vaccine yet
available so very important if you're
pregnant or you're delivering or you
haven't during the influenza season that
the vaccine makes a difference for both
of you and of course seniors over the
age of 65.
now is also the time to plan for the
holidays and we are going to make it and
we are making it even easier and more
convenient for people to get their flu
shots and their coveted vaccines too if
you're due for those and and I'll be
turning it over to Dr ballon to talk a
bit more about that in a minute
but I do want to talk a little bit about
the upcoming holiday season now is the
time to plan so that you can have a safe
and joyful holiday together with friends
and families and loved ones something we
have missed for this past two years but
we are not out of the woods completely
yet so we need to be extra sure we
continue to protect ourselves our
families and our communities as we go
into this important holiday season and
that means number one get your vaccines
and ensure children are protected too
both for influenza and for covid staying
home or away from others if you're sick
especially if you have a fever fever is
a pretty good sign that you have
something that is infectious to others
and that's an important sign that you
need to stay home and rest and recover
and take Extra Care around infants
because we know they are susceptible to
more severe illness and so we need to
protect them when we're in respiratory
season
ends regularly practicing respiratory
etiquette which means covering your
cough using your sleeve or tissue and
then disposing of it
wearing a mask if you have very mild
symptoms and you're not sure if you're
incubating something or if children in
your are sick for example in your house
and you go to work those are times when
wearing a mask is a prevention measure
is important and we should think about
postponing visits to people who may be
more at risk if you're not feeling 100
percent
we also encourage people to wear a mask
if you want that extra protection
especially if you're in a crowded indoor
setting with people you don't know
I think it's also really important for
us to remember what we've been through
in the last two years and make it okay
in your holiday plans for people not to
come or to be able to participate
remotely or outside if they or someone
in the family is not feeling well even
if they're ones that are supposed to
bring the turkey make it okay we've
found many many ways to be able to
safely be together whether it's
virtually or Outdoors if we need to and
we need to remember those ways as we go
into this this holiday season
we need to remember to be patient and
flexible this year as we transition to
more normal celebrations like we used to
have
because we still have covid-19 and also
influenza here now
I also want to talk a minute to Faith
leaders
and they I am so appreciative of the way
that Faith leaders have supported
communities across this province through
these last few years and I want to
encourage you again to find ways to
celebrate these most important days that
are coming up that people can
participate safely having the ability to
broadcast for example or to participate
remotely for those who feel sick or for
people who feel at risk and aren't
comfortable yet in being in those
settings with others the many ways Faith
leaders have been supporting their
congregations through these difficult
years those are things that we need to
to do again to get us through this year
and to be able to celebrate together
as I said typical influenza season lasts
about eight weeks so it is not too late
to make a difference now we can blunt
this curve prevent the spread to family
to loved ones by vaccination now before
the holidays so that we can have safe
and joyful Gatherings and activities
together and as I said we're going to be
making it much easier for parents to add
this into their day during this busy
time and I'll now turned over to Dr
ballon to give you some details
good morning and thanks so much Mr Dix
and Dr Henry it's always a privilege to
be here to just give our public some
basic information about you know how
they can access an influenza vaccine and
particularly today I just want to share
with you you know how we are trying to
make it easier for parents who are
currently in the busy but one of the
busiest times of the year to get their
kids vaccinated
we've had a very strong and enthusiastic
response to the influenza campaign we've
vaccinated
over 1.5 million people which is much
above last year and I believe getting to
a record in the province
we've used about 70 percent of our
vaccine and we have more in the wings
coming in if to make sure that everybody
has a chance to who wishes to get
vaccinated and generally with the
high-risk groups that Dr Henry has
identified we're doing well 50 over 50
percent of seniors over 65 have been
vaccinated
um we do track people with chronic
illness so that we can prioritize them
40 to 45 percent of them have come in
and got an influenza vaccine
and you know really Our concern as Dr
Henry has said is children
particularly those who are six months to
four years who are in the highest risk
group
they're the most vulnerable and amongst
those children we have only 20 percent
have been vaccinated
for those five to eleven twenty percent
have been vaccinated and for our teens
only 15 percent
so I think our call out today is to All
Children and Youth and particularly the
small ones to make that extra effort on
behalf of their parents to get them
vaccinated
now I think the public are very familiar
with the get vaccinated system it's it's
a remarkable way that they can be
notified of when a vaccine is due and
they can go in and you know book
themselves or their children a vaccine
in one of many options that is
convenient for them
to date though we only have about 50 000
of the most vulnerable children six
months to four years who are actually
registered in the get vaccinated system
and one of the steps that we're taking
today
is that we're going to take information
that is in the provincial registry and
use that to send a notification through
get vaccinated to parents
we know that some of those notifications
won't reach them because the telephone
number we have is possibly a landline
but parents in in the age group of
children of six months to four years are
you know very Savvy most of them operate
off mobile phones and so we're hoping
that the majority of these notifications
will go out and reach them and we will
encourage them to get their children
registered then we can send them an
invitation link and they can book an
appointment in you know many of the
health authority clinics that are around
the province waiting for them to come in
and receive their vaccine
there are lots of options available for
parents to bring their children and
youth in to get vaccinated
we have about 2 000 family doctors who
have received influenza vaccine through
the health authorities and who are able
to provide vaccination so you know
parents can can phone their family
doctor's office and see if there's
vaccine available and bring their
children in to get vaccinated
there are health authority clinics if
your family doctor does not have vaccine
and these clinics are specifically set
up to welcome children to make them
comfortable you know a few extra touches
coloring they get some of them are able
to put decorations on little Christmas
trees there are balloons and we
generally try and make those children's
clinics you know a very safe and
comfortable place for children
you know especially the little ones to
feel okay
and for infants and toddlers oh sorry
for children five to eleven they can
they can receive their vaccine at a
pharmacy as well and there are about you
know 250 pharmacies across the province
who are welcoming children in that age
group 5 to 11 and providing vaccine but
actually any pharmacy you know is is
legally able to provide vaccine to
Children 5 to 11.
so generally as you can see we've got a
lot of access around the province
um we have about 140 health authority
clinics that are designed just for
children and there are thousands of
appointments available on the get
vaccinated system
at the end of this week we'd like to
sort of have a blitz
as I called it
avaxa fluoza
to welcome kids there's a special effort
that's being planned by the health
authorities by our Pharmacy colleagues
and we hope by our family physicians to
really make an extra effort
if you get Friday Saturday and Sunday
and get a vaccine you're you're ready
for two weeks away when your immune
system has responded and you're moving
into your holiday season with your
family
so December 9th 10th and 11 a special
effort lots of walk-in availability for
families to bring their kids in there's
a lot of effort being made to make sure
that we we've got the vaccine available
and it's in convenient places and that
we're able to welcome families
we encourage families to book an
appointment if they can through get
vaccinated as I I told you a few minutes
ago we're going to send out
notifications to families who do not
have their children in that system to
encourage them to do that
so just a little note on what you need
to get your child registered and get
vaccinated BC first of all you go to the
website
getvaccinated.gov.bc.ca you need your
child's full name their phn number
their date of birth
and the postal code where they live
that's all you need and you can get your
child registered and within a few hours
you will receive an invite to actually
book them into one of the many clinics
around the province and if they're a
little bit older to a pharmacy where
they can get a vaccination
so I'm gonna I'm gonna close there just
to say we have ample vax vaccine
um most vaccines in the influenza
category can be used for children as Dr
Henry mentioned we we have some flu mist
still available and that's for children
who really have a problem with a needle
you can ask for that at the clinic
but generally there's vaccine there's a
lot of information on the government
website on the health authority websites
on the BC Pharmacy association website
and on bccdc's website for information
about influenza vaccine for where you
can get it we want to make it you know
very very easy for people to feel like
they have access to you know what do
they do and where do they go and the
provincial call center is always
available to answer pretty much any
question and book your child in if you
can't get to it using your using the
internet or online
so to all our parents of children in the
province we're here to help you and
support you in what we know is the
busiest time of year for you and your
family
please reach out to your local health
authority the provincial call center
to your local doctor and help make it
happen to protect your children thank
you so much
Mr Dix
thank you Dr Henry thank you Dr Bellum
and uh obviously vaccination are our
best tools combating influenza to
combating covid-19 and I encourage
everybody to consider booking a flu
vaccine appointment soon
as Dr ballum has said this is going to
be a record year
for flu vaccination and well that record
has been going on by our Healthcare
teams the extraordinary teams of
Pharmacists Community pharmacists of
health authority Clinics of of uh of
family doctors while all that's going on
we also have done a more than 1.5
million people to get their covid-19
booster shot and we need people to
continue to do that and adults could
continue to do that as Dr balma said 55
percent
of people 11 out of every 20 of seniors
over 65 have got their flu vaccine
however
that number can be higher and
importantly should be higher as we go
towards the holiday season so we
continue to encourage everyone in BC to
get their flu shot to get their covid-19
bivalent vaccine and there are
opportunities available to do that every
everywhere in BC the focus today is of
course on on children uh 21 between six
months and five years have received
their flu shot about 20 percent of those
five to eleven received their flu shot
about 15 12 to 17. particularly in the
first two categories though which
strongly encourage all parents to get
their children vaccinated against
influenza this year getting vaccinated
of course also helps reduce the load on
our health care workers and our health
care System we've been working
tirelessly to keep British Columbians
healthy in difficult times and I'd like
to take this opportunity to thank every
healthcare worker every health care
professional for all the work they're
doing their work is of course not easy
especially during the colder months and
the ongoing commitment of Health Care
teams to the people of BC is deeply
appreciated I know by me and by
everybody else our hospitals are ready
and continue to be ready for the surge
of patients that comes with respiratory
illness season and we will get through
this season together we've seen an
increase in emergency room visits
particularly in the provincial Health
Services Authority we're talking about
BC Children's and in the Fraser health
authority over the last month we gone
roughly in terms of emergency room
visits if you take September and October
and compare it to November through
December 2nd we've gone from about 6 700
emergency room visits a day to between
6800 and 6900 and that is increase
reflects those increases especially at
BC Children's and in the Fraser health
authority in addition we continue to be
taking measures to support our Health
Care system and uh and uh to and
especially to support our emergency
rooms where we're seeing significant and
ongoing pressure on the Health Care
System but the way we can all do this we
all have control and power as
individuals in the community the way we
can help the Health Care system is to
get vaccinated against influenza to get
vaccinated against covid-19 that is
something we all have in our hands to do
but more important than that especially
when it involves children it's an
opportunity Unity to protect them
against influenza and its impact on them
to protect them against covid-19 and its
impact on them we can all take out do
what we need to do to be ready as well
we need to get vaccinated we need to
wear a mask if we have mild symptoms we
need to stay home if we're sick we need
to wash our hands frequently we need to
keep doing what we know and keep doing
what we know works and with that we're
happy to take your questions and I'll
invite Dr Henry back to the podium
thank you to all our speakers as a
reminder for media on the phone please
press star one to enter the queue that's
star one to ask a question for media in
the room please line up at the
microphone provided and please make sure
to provide your full name and Outlet
we're going to start in the room today
so please go ahead
uh good morning syndrome with CTV
um a lot here to go through so uh let me
try this
sounds like after years of covet
that perhaps the flu is now your number
one concern is that the case and also
was there any discussion about
push for kids to limit how many adults
get the flu shot and instead just get
them straight to kids so that
do you know what I mean by that just
because there's there may not be enough
is there enough for everybody that you
may have had the discussion that perhaps
we should only give them to Children
yeah so the the first answer
um to the first question is is you know
we've been watching and we were
concerned that we would see an early
influenza season and that it would come
at the same time that we're seeing
increases in covid-19 that we've seen
seasonally for the last two years and
and that is indeed what we're seeing we
did see quite a lot of RSV but not as
much as some other parts of the country
but right now for children what is
making most children sick what we're
seeing the greatest proportion of is
influenza and influenza A and it's an
influenza A H3N2 so that's one that does
cause more severe illness historically
across the board so the answer about
whether we would reserve for flu vaccine
for children Only
We believe We have enough and we
certainly have enough for children
children right now in the province and
we see that influenza causes more severe
illness in older people as well so
unfortunately older people have the
double whammy of being very severely
affected by covid and also by influenza
and particularly influenza H3N2 so we do
need to make sure that it's available
for people at high risk whether they're
children with underlying conditions or
adults with underlying condition or
older adults so we need we do have
enough for everybody across the board
that's really important what we're
seeing that's different in children and
why we're focusing on that today is we
do know that children have mostly milder
illness with covet relative to adults
and but that's not the case for
influenza so it is really important this
year more than most other years that we
protect children as best we can
um these were very sad news of course
I'm sure you heard of Richmond uh it
looks like a six-year-old girl uh
Danielle
uh passed away from complications
through the flu
um I'm sure you've heard of this and I'm
sure uh just your reaction to that if
you could doctor sure
um we do know that there have been a
number of children around the province
who have had influenza and I I can't
comment I don't actually know the
details of this person in in particular
but uh yes we've we've had a number of
children who've had more severe illness
and one of the things that we see with
influenza that we don't see with covid
for example in children is having
secondary bacterial infections and that
cause pneumonia sometimes meningitis so
very severe infections that have
sometimes very tragic outcomes so yeah
that is something that we're you know it
it's always heartbreaking to hear about
severe illness in young children and
that's why it is so so important to do
the best that we can to protect them and
and that's where vaccine comes in our
next question we'll be going to the
phones uh Richard zusman Global News
please go ahead
and Dr Henry you've encouraged people
before to go get vaccinated and the
rates among children are still low so
what is the Hope here that will be
different this time around in terms of
increasing rates and is there any
consideration being given to
requirements around vaccination within
the school system and what tools do
those in the school system have if kids
come in sick my understanding is there's
not a lot of power a teacher has if a
student comes in and is sick to ask them
to go home
yeah so uh you know I think we're
um it's not a surprise I don't think to
parents around the province that kids
are getting sick with respiratory
illnesses right now and we're seeing
that in in absenteeism in schools where
people are are keeping children home
which is good
um but I want people to be aware that we
can still make a difference we are still
early on in this trajectory of influenza
we're starting to see the impact of a
large number of children who haven't
been exposed to influenza for a few
years and a small proportion of them are
getting severely ill so Now's the Time
to really make a difference get that
vaccine now especially we know that
there's going to be activities during
the holidays we're going to want to
spend time with family and friends and
that's a situation where we can spread
the virus even more so really important
now's the the time to get this done
we're making it easier as Dr balham said
we'll have walk-in days at clinics this
coming weekend and that gives you the
time to to protect children as best we
can as we're going into this really
important time
Richard did you have a follow-up
why not create
requirements I Know That vaccine
requirements are controversial that
cause problems in the past but but why
not put a requirement in we did it when
adults were getting very sick in the
threat of dying and there seems to be
more of reluctance now for various
different reasons like are we are we
doing as much now to protect children as
we did to protect older adults at the
height of covet yeah that's a really
interesting question I mean influenza is
something that we've uh we've been
living with for for many many years and
Seasons tend to to fluctuate the vaccine
is available
um most children do have mild illness
especially school-aged children are
mostly have a mild illness from
influenza as well but we know that they
can amplify it and spread it in in their
families and in in communities so it is
partly a uh where do we where do we see
influenza having the most severe effects
and of course the most severe effects
that are in younger children who aren't
in school we do have
um promotion for for children for
influenza vaccinations but we haven't
made them a requirement in any
situations with the exception of the The
long-standing vaccinator Mask policy
that we had in healthcare settings so we
focus on
mandates if you will in those settings
where they're going to have the most
impact and where it makes the most
difference and that's why we still have
mass mandates in all of our health care
settings where we still have a
vaccination mandates for covid and the
requirement for influenza vaccination in
health care settings because those are
the settings where the most vulnerable
people may be exposed we we generally
have not had vaccination requirements
for children
for a whole variety of things that can
spread in schools what we do have is the
reporting requirement that came into
place in 2018 the that where we have
reporting of vaccination status of
children in schools influence is not
part of that because it is a vaccine
that changes every year and that we need
to update every year with the changing
influenza virus
so it is a a balancing of where these
have the most impact and where they have
the most benefit and mandates are always
sort of The Last Resort
I don't know if you want to speak to
that at all
and just just to say Richard you recall
in 2019 when we dealt with um I think at
the time uh 29 cases of the measles in
BC but given
um that we had largely eradicated the
measles that was a significant issue
what we did at that time was what we're
doing today which is dramatically is
significantly improving access and
providing the public with information
about what they need to do especially to
protect their children one of the things
that was so important in that time was
the number of children 16 17 and 18 who
chose to get immunized against measles
at that time right now the situation is
that roughly 21 of those six months to
four years and 364 days who are eligible
are are vaccinated against influenza at
this time and as you know the numbers on
cloven 19 are are also in the same range
or lower and so I think what we're
saying to people today is take advantage
especially in this pre-holiday season
you can still have uh that have an
impact to protect your children as
individuals which is the most important
thing but also to protect the community
we found this to be effective you'll
recall I think in spite of the small
number of people hadn't been vaccinated
against against measles at that time
about 38 000 took part in that a lot of
them were 16 17 18 year olds who are
making that decision for themselves at
that time so I think I think that's the
effective way of dealing on the issue of
vaccination we do have course vaccine
requirements in our health care System
we do have mass requirements in our
health care System but this is an
opportunity for everyone and I think Dr
Henry has said it well that we this is
an opportunity right now to positively
affect the situation for the whole
Community most importantly for your
child
our next question we're going to Vaughn
Palmer Vancouver Sun please go ahead
Mr Henry thank you for doing this as
always uh the
19 operations review that was released
Friday by the government
reported on what it characterizes an
erosion of trust in public health
measures and expressed the concern that
it could translate into more public
resistance to advice on public health
measures
um do you think that may be a factor in
why so many parents have so far not got
their children vaccinated for either the
flu or covet
uh it's uh it's an interesting question
I think part of it is that you know
we've been talking about this for a long
time and until it becomes very real
there's uh sometimes uh a challenge in
fitting it into a busy day and and
especially parents of young children
they have a lot going on a lot going on
right now and that's why we need to make
it as easy as possible for parents to to
do what they need to do with children
and I hear that from from parents all
the time that oh yeah we're going to get
the kids vaccinated we just had this
going on and that going on in school and
it's busy and so what we're doing today
is saying it's really important what
we're seeing is children are being
affected we know that in the holidays we
want to get together again and it's
important for us to do that we need to
do that this year so the best thing we
can do now is make it easy for you to
drop into a clinic anywhere in the
province bring your children you can get
your vaccine too and we'll get it all
done so we can have the safest holidays
possible
Yvonne did you have a follow-up
yes please the operations review also
recommended well in one of their
findings that uh the provincial Health
officer can or office conduct a review
of Public Health measures during
covid-19 to determine uh which ones
worked best is that a review that you
would be open to doing and if so when
would it likely be conducted yeah I
think it is something that we're not
only open to doing but are doing
um not just us but across the country
and we're talking with my colleagues and
globally it's very very challenging
though just to put this on the table to
tease apart you know because many of
these things came in together and I
talked about that a little bit on our
last call when we had a lot of covid and
many many people were were vulnerable we
needed to put in layers of protections
because we didn't have vaccination for
example example and was causing severe
illness across the board so those layers
of protections that we put in it's very
difficult to tease out was one better
than the other or was it the combination
of them and then as the the immunity
went up and as cases went down we no
longer needed to have the multiple
different barriers so yes we absolutely
are committed to trying to understand
which combinations as best we can worked
best in which situations I think one of
the things that I took out of that
report and that I've been thinking a lot
about myself and with my colleagues over
the past
two and a half years almost three years
now is is the fact that things changed
things changed a lot during this last
three years it's a long period of time
the virus changed our immunity changed
and Immunity is complex the things that
we were doing changed what was happening
globally changed and every time there's
a change trying to adjust to it and
trying to find the best least
restrictive means of doing things was a
challenge that we had so things like the
testing protocols change for a whole
variety of reasons and part of that was
people have to get become we have to
become comfortable with changing tactics
as the situation changes but that's
always that's not always easy and we get
to into a pattern we understand certain
things and it becomes challenging when
things change and we no longer know what
to do and that anxiety causes a lot of
concern for people so I think we as a
community and public health and myself
in particular need to to learn how to
talk more about change and communicate
why we're doing things and why the
changes are and and help people with
that anxiety that comes with with things
changing over time so it's certainly
something that I'm very interested in
and and how do we do that in a way that
helps build up trust again
for our next question we're going to
Justine Hunter Globe and Mail please go
ahead
thank you um I Heard the health Minister
say that hospitals in BC are ready for
this surge we had a story over the
weekend that shows hospitalizations of
children with a flu have skyrocketed
across the country uh 223 children
admitted in 12 hospitals with the flu
where normally we would have 11. can you
tell me what the admittance rate is
right now in BC and how would you
describe the state of capacity right now
for Pediatric ER
um a couple of things I think your story
in Globe mail showed that many
jurisdictions have it worse than us but
that it's a significant situation here
in BC in a general sense we're seeing an
increase in emergency room visits at BC
Children's that everyone can see which
is the result of it being respiratory
illness season
in terms of pediatric and neonatal ICU
it's been relatively stable in November
and December against September and
October overall we're seeing
approximately 200 people more a day in
terms of our daily census in hospitals
across BC I think the important thing to
remember though is that obesity
children's is very important and
significant and obviously a site of
Interest really it's affecting every
hospital in BC we tend to have a lower
level of occupancy at BC Children's than
we do at hospitals that take all
patients and that's certainly the case
right now so yes I think if you look at
what we've seen for example in Interior
Health in terms of emergency room visits
against a typical November they're
significantly higher I think they went
from about three for Respiratory illness
from about 300 to about a thousand in
Interior Health and that's what we're
seeing and that's what we're responding
to so that means we're taking a series
of actions in emergency rooms
particularly at BC Children's as you
know the the opening up of of
triage and BC Children's and I'll just
if you if you'd like
Justine just list off what we've done
since the those announcements we made it
our November 16th briefing we obviously
at Victoria General Hospital we now have
pediatricians providing care in the ER
BC at Children's has activated their
emergency department satellite Clinic uh
and we would expect that clinic to still
be in place right through tentatively
through to March 31st 2023 or until the
surge abates effective next week Surry
Memorial have a process to redirect some
patients from the Ed to an emergency to
Emergency Room Physicians at the Surrey
urgent and Primary Care Center Children
and Youth in White Rock South Surrey
have opened we've opened a pediatric
access to Rapid Care Clinic at Peace
Arch Hospital which has a positive
impact there and there's a series of
actions that of course were put in place
before including the opening up of
long-term care beds 187 of them in order
to move people who should be in
long-term care from acute care to
long-term care and those beds are
continuing to open so those are the
steps we're taking to prepare our Health
Care system and but I think the key
message from us today and is that
there's another way we can all do that
and that's increased our rate of
vaccination against influenza and just
note in terms of the question I think
that Vaughn asked earlier one of the
differences we've seen is 2020 and 2021
we had relatively mild influenza season
and that was that is a significant
effect on people getting flu shots so
there may well be children who Who as a
result of that haven't got flu shots in
previous years well they need to get
them this year influenza has come back
as it as it was in a number of years
prior to covid-19 and so that's a real
change and so I continue to give that
message we're going to have a record
number of people getting flu shots this
year but a record number is not what
we're looking for we're looking for as
many people as possible and if it's your
child your loved one your grandmother
Your Grandparent whoever it is that's
vulnerable we need everyone or as many
people as possible to get immunized both
against covet 19. of course but
especially right now against influenza
Justine did you have a follow-up
yeah thank you um you did list off a
whole bunch of things that BC has done
um is there uh
can you explain
why we haven't got the message out and
we knew that there was a flu season
um that was coming early there was a new
system put in place through the get
vaccinated program
um
I guess I'm wondering what's going to
change this weekend
to get parents to get their kids in and
why weren't we doing that accessibility
piece perhaps earlier
well we have we're just making uh the
point of it now again I talked about
this in September we talked about it in
November
pediatricians across the province have
been reaching out to to children in
their practice to get the message out
this is just reiterating that yes we do
need to and to try and give a talk again
about the fact that there are walk-in
clinics drop in walk-in weekend next
weekend
and making sure that we're adjusting the
clinic schedules so that parents are
aware that they can do this and making
special efforts over the next little
while and it partly is you know when
where we are in the influenza season and
it's partly because we're heading up to
the holiday season so I want to get that
message out to people that we can still
do things that will make a difference
and make it better for us and our loved
ones and our families in the coming
holidays okay
for our next question we'll go to Lisa
USDA city news please go ahead
hi there just
just wondering why if this isn't so
urgent right now which it clearly is why
not just drop the get vaccinated part
entirely and just let people walk in
wherever they want to get this vaccine
and I'm also wondering with that if you
can also talk about the efficacy of this
vaccine like
how great of protection do you get from
it
yeah so influenza vaccines as you know
change every year depending on the
strains that were that we expect to see
circulating
and this year so far we've been seeing
across this country and and the us as
well primarily influenza A H3N2 as I
mentioned and so far the the lab tests
are telling us that it's a very good
match to what's in the vaccine so the
vaccines that we have this year they
have two strains of H of influenza A so
an H3 and an H1 strain an H1N1 strain
and they have both strains of the the B
virus as well so unfortunately we can't
tell the vaccine efficacy until enough
people have been vaccinated and we've
seen enough cases in both vaccinated and
unvaccinated people so it's one of those
things that we could look at
retrospectively but all the indications
so far are that there's a very good
match with the vaccine so we know that
when there's a good match match we can
get uh you know 50 to 70 percent
protection against infection and against
illness with it with influenza so it's
not that we're saying that it just
started today we've been saying this for
the last few months we just want to
reiterate to people that it's not too
late the vaccine is still available get
vaccinated is the easiest way to do it
but we know that there are challenges
particularly parents with young children
there's lots going on so we have
increased the availability for younger
children and we're just reminding people
that it's going to be available
especially in the in the next coming
days
thanks Dr Henry and maybe I could just
add a couple of points
um you know the get vaccinated system
has been you know uh
highly highly appreciated by the public
they really like that they can book an
appointment and uh we've had an enormous
amount of feedback
after the initial sort of change where
people said oh I used to walk in and now
now you want me to make an appointment
and I think you know at the very
beginning of the campaign it was a
little bit shaky as people got used to
the notion that they they could actually
get a notification and book a vaccine
but generally it's been really well
received and it just provides the
clarity and certainty for people that
they know where they can get it it's
they don't have to phone around to
different places they can go on this one
system and see the many options for them
on a geographic basis so it's been
really successful and I think in part
accounts for the the very high uptake
we've had the difficulty that we have
with children especially the small
children is that they're not in the
system and we haven't been able to
notify their parents and so we we've
done some
work with the government and and with
the data set and the PIR in the
provincial registry for vaccination and
we're going to work backwards from there
and and be able through the get
vaccinated system to send notifications
out and that's as I said I'm going to
start today and there's about a hundred
and fifty thousand children who aren't
in that system that once they're in we
can invite them and their parents then
can can make an appointment or we we
will welcome them if they walk in you
know generally
um Staffing up for the uncertainty if
everyone decides to walk in and some
people book it it does make it less
efficient for everyone for staff and and
for people who end up queuing to get
into a clinic if there are a lot of
drop-ins so this Smooths it out but as
Dr Henry has said we we want to make the
next few days and particularly next
weekend Friday Saturday Sunday a time
when we're really putting a massive
effort on to allow people to walk in
make an appointment get into our clinics
and
call their doctor's offices and you know
visit pharmacies if they're old enough
to get a vaccine in pharmacies and and
get get the job done and get them
protected for the Christmas or the
holiday season
thanks Lisa did you have a follow-up
I'm just wondering a couple things I'm
going to throw in here like do we know
how many kids are absent from school how
great that is and why not do you know
I'm 20 seems incredibly low for 5 to 11
year olds 15 for teenage teenagers why
not just do a couple of vaccinations
within schools I know there's you know a
lot of Workforce for it but if it's that
urgent why not why not use that we just
have the HPV one at our kids school and
it was incredibly efficient
yeah and in some cases around the
province they are doing school-based
clinics
um for the most part though especially
for the younger children we've heard
from families that that's not their
preferred place to have children
immunized although we do often use
schools and after hours because they're
familiar places for parents with young
children to bring them in to be
immunized so it is trying to find the
right place in the right setting and in
some smaller communities yeah the
vaccination clinics are often in in
schools are associated with schools but
all of the clinics around the province
now are also providing covid and
influenza vaccination so you can get
them both at the same time in terms of
absenteeism that is something that the
superintendents and the individual
schools report on regularly and have a
good sense of and yes we have seen
increased absenteeism the biggest
concern that we have of course is that
schools are able to function safely and
for most part that that has been we've
been managing around the province and I
think it's a reflection as well of of
lots of children getting mostly milder
illness thankfully but also that people
are doing the right thing and keeping
children home and and I know it's a it's
a stressful thing sometimes when lots of
kids are sick but uh we we are expecting
to see this particularly this year when
we haven't seen RSV for a while we
haven't seen influenza for a few years
that is going to be and that we still
have covet here so this is going to be a
transition year I believe and then you
know hopefully by the time we get to
next respiratory season we'll be in a
better place
for our next question Jane scribnick
black prince please go ahead
hey there thanks for taking my questions
um I just wanted to confirm one thing
with you Minister dicks uh you mentioned
300 to a thousand cases of respiratory
illness among kids in Interior Health
um can you confirm what time period was
that over and do you have similar
numbers for the rest of the other health
authorities
yeah we can we can get you that those
numbers are from Dr Fenton in Interior
Health they reflect the situation there
so that's an increase in visits to
emergency departments from November to
November
um for uh for Respiratory conditions so
that's that's the specific statistic
we're talking about and Dr Fenton talked
about that in uh in some media
discussions uh over the over the past
weekend
and Jane did you have a follow-up
yeah I'm also just wondering how far
along into the six to eight week uh
influenza season we are right now
yeah so we look at the data that we
started to see quite a dramatic increase
about two weeks ago so I would say we're
in the the sort of two to three week
phase of it
um it tends to last two to three or you
know two months or so so uh it's not too
late to make a difference and we've seen
it level off a little bit in in older
teens but uh definitely increasing still
in the younger children so not
surprising this is what we saw in in
Australia and New Zealand as well that
had a very steep Peak what we hope and
why we're talking again today is is we
can we can blunt that Peak and we can
prevent that ongoing transmission to
older adults as we come together over
the holiday season which is often often
when we see we see our influenza peaking
before this pandemic what we saw was our
peak of our season tended to be in
January after the holidays when people
were mixing and there was more spread so
we want to prevent that this year and we
have the opportunity to do that by
making sure we we take some action today
that will make a difference
Rob Monroe info news please
hi I just want to clarify if I heard Mr
Dix correctly saying those interior
numbers were from November of last year
to November of this year which means
we're not really comparing apples and
oranges but why the interior would
possibly be be worse off than other
places
foreign
is not necessarily worse off this is a
province-wide Circumstance the numbers
and the response that BC Children's is
typically more weighted to Metro
Vancouver although obviously BC
Children's takes patients from uh
throughout the province all this is is a
regular reporting that's done through
Interior Health that talks about that Dr
Fenton talked about this weekend with
respect to Interior Health but I think
what we're seeing is amongst children is
a is a more significant influenza season
by a very significant margin than last
year and that reflects that the the
presentation at emergency departments
reflects that but look I mean you want
to take a step back to where we were in
2021
through from in Interior Health August
September October November in Northern
Health August September October November
with the Delta variant of concern of
covid-19 in that period we've we flew
people in the hundreds who were from ICU
so these were every case serious down to
Southern British Columbia hospitals in
order to support them with care that's
what occurred in that time and we had a
very challenging time as you'll recall
and throughout that period there was
deferrals for example of non-urgent
scheduled surgeries so we've been we've
been going through this for two and a
half years what makes this qualitatively
different is influenza against last year
which is significantly higher which has
been higher in every jurisdiction in the
country and is higher here in BC so
that's what we're seeing but I don't
think it's particularly more significant
in Interior Health than everywhere else
it's a challenge everywhere in BC and
that's why everywhere in BC it's
important that people get vaccinated
Rob did you have a follow-up
yeah I just want to keep this in
perspective a bit when you talk about 21
of the youngest children being
vaccinated this year
um we can't compare that to last year
the year before because of coping that
how does that 21 percent
compare to say 2018 2019 the more
typical historically typical uh fuses
that we've had
short answer is we we don't really know
for a variety of reasons
um and as you said you know last year
influenza vaccination we we didn't
record it in the same way that we're
doing it this year so with the get
vaccinated system and recording of
influenza immunizations into our
provincial immunization registry we have
a much better idea of who's getting
vaccinated and their age their risk Etc
so it's very difficult to compare we
hadn't been recording influenza
vaccinations in the same way prior to
having this system that we have now in
place so we do know that from surveys
that were done in in 2018 2019 that we
would have you know up to 30 percent of
children vaccinated but it varied
depending on the year and depending on
the severity of influenza and it that
was always an estimate so we have a
better estimate this year uh the one
area doesn't include is people who were
vaccinated at their Physician's offices
because we we don't yet have a direct
link to put those immunizations into our
immunization registry and we'll be
working on that because it is really
helpful for all of us to know where what
rates we have of vaccination but also so
that we can get our own vaccination
records once they're into the
immunization registry
our next question is for Ashley joano
Canadian press please go ahead okay
hi good afternoon
um you mentioned going into the
provincial registry to reach out to the
families of kids who aren't getting
vaccinated can you uh talk to me a
little bit about what that's actually
going to look like are people getting
text messages are they actually getting
phone calls from from another human who
can answer their questions about the
vaccine like what what will that
actually look like for these parents who
aren't part of the system
yeah thanks so much uh really great
question
the get vaccinated system will use
mostly the phone number the information
that we have in the registry
for people who've never registered and
get vaccinated is usually an address and
a phone number very occasionally you may
have an email if there's an email and or
a phone number we will send a text
message and if there is an email address
we'll send an email so we're using all
the information that the get vaccinated
system can leverage to actually try and
reach these parents and as I said a bit
earlier we know that it we won't get
everybody and that's part of the reason
why you know we have a pretty
significant communication campaign going
on a lot of social media
from the government and from the health
authorities the pharmacy Association
urging people to get vaccinated telling
them how to do that as well as you know
a number of we have posters there's a
lot of activity around the influenza
season to let people know but this is
you know a much more direct and targeted
response to parents of the very smallest
children six months to four years who as
Dr Henry has said are are the most
vulnerable along with our seniors for
the impact of influenza
so text or or email if we have that
available
Ashley did you have a follow-up
I do yeah thanks um so over the weekend
a Code Orange was declared at the
Children's Hospital I'm hoping that you
can talk a bit about why that was called
and how close we are to that happening
again
uh yeah the Code Orange was called at 6
35 a.m and canceled at 703 am it was
enacted based on the information at the
time and uh but it was canceled when it
was determined that the code did not
need to be enacted in order to make a
mandatory OT call out which is what was
required so people are managing as you
can imagine have been managing the
healthcare system on a routine basis in
that case someone triggered the code
orange with the best information more
information came in and it was canceled
I think 28 minutes later
our next question is from wire whiten
the Thai please go ahead
[Music]
hi thank you for taking my question
um Dr Henry you mentioned earlier that
um you know you you want to use mandates
as a last resort where they will have
the most impact and benefit can you talk
to me about why
um masks in schools aren't on the table
for you right now given that children
are being the most impacted as you said
yeah and you know masking is one of the
measures that is needed in certain
situations and I talked about that a
little bit in answer to uh Von Palmer's
question you know it was one of the
layers that was absolutely needed at a
period of time where we had a lot of
transmission of covet and in the context
where we had a number of other measures
in place reduced capacity limits
increased ventilation which is still an
issue making sure that we had the
ability to work roommate remotely or to
have remote teaching if needed Etc so
there was a whole bunch of activity
restrictions travel restrictions that
were in place when we had a a mandate
now we're in a very different situation
there are a number of different viruses
that are out there circulating that are
transmitted between children in many
different settings and having only a
mask mandate and only in schools is very
unlikely to have any difference and
effect on the trajectory of the viruses
that are circulating in our community so
a mandate is a is a rather heavy-handed
measure that we do as a last resort when
it's something that is absolutely needed
everywhere all the time and right now
we're in a place where we have measures
that can help mitigate the effects and
we can prevent transmission of some of
these viruses through vaccination and
that's why that's so important and
there's other measures that we all need
to take on an ongoing basis we've talked
about those staying away from others
when we're sick ourselves wearing Mass
when it's appropriate or when we feel we
need that extra piece of a bit of
protection for ourselves depending on
the situation we're in but it's not at a
place where we would require that as a
sole measure as a mandate across the
board we do have mass mandates in the
settings where it's most important that
we have that additional layer of
protection and that's in our health care
settings right now
why are we not vaccinating kids in
schools right now we've seen in other
provinces have really good uptake on
Cova vaccines and other vaccine courses
in schools and it seems like there's
quite a bit of urgency to blunt the ways
that you said so why aren't we going
into schools I'll I'll start and I can
turn it over as we talked about before
there's a you know the highest risk age
group for children uh are you know the
children six months to five years of age
who are eligible for vaccination and of
course they're not in schools
um there is an important vaccination
programs that are run in schools and in
some parts of the province where it
makes sense schools are a place where
people can get vaccinated for covet and
for influenza as well but we know and
we've heard from parents that most of
them would prefer to have it done at
their family doctor's office or in a
public health clinic that's established
for children so they can bring all of
their children regardless of the age and
have immunization be provided to the
family together
we have time for one more question our
final question today goes to Mira Baines
CBC please go ahead
hi I would like the answers in English
and French for my French colleagues
um this one has already been answered in
English so I just need the French answer
hopefully for Minister dicks uh the
question is you know why not bring in
mandatory flu vaccines in schools and
also as part of that you know why not
vaccinate children in schools yeah so
we've talked about the vaccination
clinics in schools the the other thing I
would say is you know we with all of
these viruses we tend to spread them to
the people that we have most contact
with they spread in families they spread
in our social connections our social
groups and so schools in and of
themselves are not the only setting
where we're seeing transmission and it
is unclear if we would even affect the
trajectory of what we're seeing in terms
of spread unless we had all of those
other settings where we didn't have
people in contact where we had other
measures in place and that's what we've
seen over the last two years that when
we don't have those social activities we
don't have those sports activities we
don't have people Gathering it traveling
we can stop transmission of respiratory
viruses but we also know that that has a
tremendous effect particularly on
children on their emotional health their
physical health their well-being so you
know we have to balance risk and the
measures that we have that can help
prevent transmission that don't
interfere with all of those important
social connections and activities that
especially children need but we all need
in our communities and so it is trying
to find the right balance as I've said
for several years now of of
looking at the whole picture not just
focusing on reducing transmission of a
virus but all of the things that we can
do to protect ourselves when we're in
groups together but recognizing that
those things that we do whether it's
getting together with family and friends
and whether it's participating in sports
events and tournaments and other things
those are also important for us in in
terms of our growth and well-being as a
society
nope CBA
developed three pounds
is
[Music]
the opportunity
some
premium Advantage
is
a very um
the vaccinations
mirror did you have a Fallout
yes
um and this one in French and English
too if possible
um this is certain young patients
admitted to hospitals what's the split
or breakdown in respiratory illnesses
between flu RSV and covid around the
province
and you may yeah
a relative stability
um
foreign
[Music]
and I think I got most of that but
enough maybe not all of it but I just
say there's a couple of things that we
look at to help us understand what's
causing infection across the province
and there we do report that on the new
respiratory dashboard on the bccdc
website and you can look at it by health
authority one of the key things that we
look at is the number it's what we call
lab-based surveillance so when somebody
gets a test and we've done this for
years during respiratory season if they
get a test for Respiratory illness
whether it's in the emergency department
in a physician's office that all goes to
the lab and we do what's called a
multiplex test in the lab so if there's
somebody's concerned about covid
concerned about influenza we have a test
that allows us a PCR test that looks for
influenza A influenza B RSV and now
we've added covert to that so that's
what we call a multiplex test so one of
our key ways of understanding ending
what's causing illness respiratory
illness around the province is looking
at that Multiplex test and by age group
and seeing which what viruses come back
positive so that's on the dashboard and
we also have a system where we've been
looking at the lab at Children's
Hospital for many years and you can go
back to the old influenza flu bulletins
and see the data there and we've now
added covet to that so if somebody gets
a test when they're in hospital in
children's hospital or in the emerge at
Children's Hospital and it goes to the
lab they automatically do those five
virus tests for those five viruses and
that's what helps us understand
what What proportion of different
viruses are circulating in both of those
lab-based surveillance so it's not
individuals it's based on the the first
test that people have and that lab-based
surveillance is what tells us that we're
seeing a lot of influenza that we're
seeing
RSV he had peaked and was leveling off
and that covet was very young very low
in in children and we're also it was
broken down by age we see that covet is
much more common in older people either
hospitalized or people being tested with
a PCR test so that's one of the main
ways we can tell which viruses are
circulating in which parts of the
province and that's based on lab testing
we also have other pieces of
surveillance and it's all a bit of a
puzzle so that we can say you know who's
getting admitted to hospital what age
group what are they being admitted with
we have what we call the Sentinel
physician or Sentinel provider
surveillance Network spsn that we've had
for many years and now we've added covid
to that and that gives us a sense of how
many people are visiting Community
providers with respiratory symptoms and
we can tell where it's happening in
different parts of the province so there
are a bunch of different pieces that we
put together to help us understand
what's happening across the province and
in different areas of the province and
all of those are in on the respiratory
dashboard on the bccdc website
the questions we have for today thank
you everyone for joining thank you very
much